one of my favorite childhood memories
was getting teriyaki chicken fried rice
from the food court at the mall so I
made it at home and it was absolutely
delicious it brought back all the feels
and memories let's get into it first
things first seasonal chicken thighs
with the following spices mix and set
aside for my version of teriyaki sauce I
combined soy sauce which gives some
Umami mirin a sweet Japanese rice
vinegar sugar and finish with ginger and
garlic next we're gonna cook our chicken
thighs I love a little Char on mine so
let mines go for 10 to 15 minutes after
that I removed it and added our teriyaki
sauce mixture let it come to a light
boil and then add our cornstarch slurry
is shaking nice and thick add your
chicken folks this was so good if you
want the fried rice recipe just let me
know